back up my broccolini get your life
together
I'm not touching
Robocop Robocop somebody hits you with
an out route and it's over your garden
Ecija your garden ASIMO hey dude that's
the world out baby son does that happen
in you guys's cultures were you sleep
wrong in your net you get this thing in
your neck a very white thing oh really
yeah all the time oh really was more of
a white thing why would it be a wiping
everything well I hope people wake up
still yeah and I think my step jeeps
know you have Jeeps
yeah you've got classic cars cars cars
bro there's tons of dude what there's
tons of stuff that white people don't
have all right I just thought that I
thought that Vietnamese or Asian
cultures would have cuz you always see
them being more like the people that
handle body like if I go get a good
massage it's always some like said you
want agent yeah I want my massage like I
want my sushi what happenes people
making it
I feel like Asian people are really good
at taking care of other people but not
themselves that's why we wake up Steph
see do you wake up surfer do you have
like a remedy a [ __ ] organic like
remedy they can make out of honey like
wasabi again help my neck I could see
yeah I could see Asian peoples getting
up and just beating each other with
freakin hibiscus trees until they're
beautiful yet see my back like a bonsai
tree so they're you would definitely be
a baritone you got that baritone know a
couple bonsais bro yeah only cut your
[ __ ] jacking off
I just wanna cut the sleeves off dude
very widest you only get that Ari rock
climbing very wide really oh there's a
lot of black rock climbers are no
there's not how do you know Brendan oh
really
yeah don't going to REI we look at
blonds are a [ __ ] little Wayne let me
know it go
[Laughter]
now they've climbed a journey and Boston
can you look up black um can we look all
right sorry can we look up can we look
at black rock climbers I hope so you
seem so low the best rock climber of all
time did you did it without a rope oh
here we go right here
whoa okay well if you go home black rock
climbers really get it black or how
close man oh there's a guy right there
this guy something is running from white
people Oh brothers are climbing they
represent and reach says in the article
it's a new Jordan Peele movie you can
tell it I saw that coming Brandon put it
in the in the chamber is straighten his
back a little yeah let's click on some
of these pictures there there's one with
the arm there yeah that guy oh there we
go that's a white guy rock climbing
yeah black rock climbing or black ah
you're asked to be a problem for that
rock climbing dude it's yet it I'm back
heavy hmm I'm built like a bookend [ __ ]
someone can that caboose up the mountain
dude look at this guy right there back
city dude Jerome Horton is a UH good
rock climb
preacher Lawson he does it too I'm gonna
start doing so I have a culture corner
it's right off you would be you're
pretty you're heavy to feel like you'd
bat flip back flip
goddamn Mountain yeah but I feel like a
is there a lot of Asian rock common
there probably is I could see that being
there yeah American Ninja Warrior they
have that show yeah absolutely the Apple
Store
sometimes you gotta climb a mountain to
get to school in China damn that's true
whoa Oh what is this it's dry for next
week for some rock climbing who's this
Geron Horton he's a comedian oh there he
is Rock come and go down on the one with
two a little more a little more right
there on the right yeah there he is
well that's indoor though that's that
are yeah but I went with him but still I
think he could probably do it outdoors
too if he was outdoors you never know to
get out there and try it you know that's
true it's like practice watching about
practice practice practice
you know it does look fun he's tall long
long and like you know something like
it's nothing
yeah he'll go up there and do nothing
he'll go up there and have a lemonade or
something go up there make lemonade
yeah man eights Dan'l you to freaking
customers he'll be out higher up there
yeah Newton you got a strong mouth to us
on the whole point you just like that
where the Suckerfish you had a tank is
okay unbelievable moves coming out of
your iron Horton right there the sucker
fish the real MVP when you think about
two of them they clean the tank for you
you don't need the filter Soudan imagine
you're a couple fish you're at a bar
hanging out dude your wife's out of town
right into these bad [ __ ] roll up the
sucker you know you one of your boys is
gonna your when your boys gonna feel
about how was Canada Oh Canada both in
Canada we were a couple maybe and leave
yeah good or just men yeah just man in
Canada dude I love Canada man to love it
I can move there so easily I stayed at
that Trump Hotel you did on accident
yeah really
that [ __ ] was badass though is it
nobody's there you have the whole place
to yourself oh really you were seeing
blank check that little kid had that
giant crib to himself and just did
whatever you want that's what I felt
like
but I'm 36 damn it's probably a
write-off though for Trump anyway I bet
I don't know I don't know there's nobody
there really I was the only person
saying the hotel
whatever I wanted that five-star service
man nobody in the restaurant six hot the
other comics kind of roasted me for
staying or whatever dog oh stay where
you want man I stayed at a place in
Toronto and what was going on there
do you see Drake there I didn't see
drink but people were talking about him
a little bit we running through the sick
I think I was for a little about jog for
a little it was real cold that count
yeah
Trudeau towers Trudeau towers Trudeau
towers yes Prime Minister went chocolate
face right yeah but his daddy's snuck
him into it that's how he got into it
that sort of heard on the DL his daddy
got him the job oh really yeah Trudeau
yeah he did black face and face dude and
let's go let's go I mean but he's a he's
a Latin he also charges went with the
wrong tone yes well yeah maybe they were
out of the brown awesome son it stung to
get the brown I've never seen anybody
that out of the brown can we click on
the can we get the picture larger here's
the problem that there with those maple
hose up top left hate but here's the
thing he said he was in high school at
the time ain't nobody buying that but
off Canada bought it he's on high school
leave those guys with beards all in
Canada broke wait what is this it's a
costume party and he's like oh I'm gonna
go as whatever like the Jafar he said
Aladdin he went for Javad those are boys
JaVale McGee Bailey's in eighth grade
look whether you guys are pedophiles or
not isn't the question whether and
here's the question for the culture coin
you do you have no issue with it yeah
well I have issue with some of it if you
go I liked it if you're gonna go like
kind of like I feel like you should be
able to impersonate your favorite
characters like say if you like like
Luke Cage or something you know and
you're a kid and you want to be
cage but you can't mm-hmm you know but
if you're like dressing up like a black
person to be mean or dressing up like a
name in front of them yeah yeah then
that's [ __ ] crazy I mean he went full
out of it we even dipped his hands in
something yeah yeah I think he went too
dark though I feel like he used even
squid or something no what do you do
again I'm I'm a little bit of a pastor
this is tough to get that Oh harbor loan
Jimmy Kimmel's Carmen he was so funny
his car Malone buzzy it was so [ __ ]
funny better make up you get fired today
I mean yeah it's I mean it's definitely
I think it's hit or miss really it's
just so yeah yeah come up with better
costumes Jimmy Kimmel [ __ ] was funny
though a little fact about car Malone he
was the mailman means he dropped loads
and girls and then be like oh you have a
kid piece I'm out really yeah mailman
didn't follow up with his kids really
one of his kids plays are two is seven
of his kids I think playing bass no play
football for Georgia yeah he plays
football for Georgia but he doesn't know
his daddy really he has a daughter that
I think played great ball he played out
there at Louisiana Tech that's right
he's a Louisiana boy in me yeah who's
dropping them packages off in your girl
and then just not following up was he I
think I thought he got the nickname
playing basketball no no the mailman or
that seaman pigeon good player though oh
yeah he's pretty good what else are we
talking about out in the lobby I felt
like oh you talking about Wilder oh yeah
huh well not really not much of a fight
what a beat-down I can't believe you
Wilder didn't put up a better fight I
mean - I know so disappointed and then
today he came out was like oh it's
because I wore that costume that weighed
40 pounds I was like dude that's some
bull [ __ ] that's a Mardi Gras costumes
people ride nine hours in that thing on
the back of a parade float and then and
party off to the wee hours of the
morning as feed a child yeah dance all
night and get pregnant
it does look heavy but I'll give them
that looks heavy he was kind of like
damn what should I go with kind of like
but shredder meets Lord of the Rings
like it's so ridiculous man he looks
like a dude who gives or gives a ton of
oil changes but is not good at giving
oil change what about this though I felt
like watching the big guys fight it
doesn't seem like they hit each other
that I do when you're watching it it
seems like they don't hit each other as
hard as when I'm watching the like the
featherweights fight and stuff that's me
man no it hits harder than those two big
fellas you think yeah yeah oh yeah he's
bleeding off his goddamn air yeah
[ __ ] punch in the face
here that would hurt I'd be so upset and
you can't call a timeout can you know
there's no timeouts you fill in the
towel if you want to hit the locker room
though you should get at least a timeout
yeah and that man licked his neck to do
that [ __ ] the boys wild ain't talking my
wilder the boys wild
crazy hook yeah I can't believe it win
at it like that though but I wonder if
they knew it almost makes you wonder to
think if he had a deed he had a thing in
his contract for a third fight yep swear
box and works then did that but did also
fury have it if he wanted a third fight
yeah no only the loser the loser gets
the loser yeah cuz they're both coming
in as world champions that's why he
doing a boxing but also like I'm not
trying to see that [ __ ] I'm good yeah
there wasn't a fight
the first one was in a fight this one
definitely in a fight are you doing a
third time yeah
goddammit boxing you just need Wilder to
come out without trunks just completely
naked so he's fresh yeah I would love
that the entrances were pretty dope
though it definitely everything's
starting to get all WWE I'm telling you
everything is turning what either
they've been doing that for Hassan
he came out on uh carried out like a
some hoes these tits in the front do
really tits in the front tits in the
back you can't see the girls but he had
some like
straight up Mortal Kombat house Katrina
and the from its katana not Katrina
oh my bad I think in New Orleans oh he
had that beautiful head his wife or
something with him I think when you have
a wife out there yeah she's all camera
she's all about what's going on cats
still single what's up with you can
still single
okay still hanging in there okay just
doing the damn thing man huh yeah why
don't you set her up with someone
Brendan ah cuz all my friends are
batshit crazy man I don't want to see
her you know go through that you know
I'm being a good friend by not setting
her you know any friends you know in our
neck or chin it's taken taken take and
take it
I think I can have a car so I can't do
that yeah but you're chatting Colonials
bro that needs wheels to gets good luck
in Asian culture dude bad luck oh you
didn't have a car right now
maybe a little Gianni the twink that
works over at this past weekend he's too
small he's too much of a twink
she likes the older man yeah that's true
I'll keep my eyes open
yeah I'll see what I can do Kat but none
of my friends are gonna work what about
um what else you doing what about one of
the Sklar brothers oh you have to date
half of look do you really I can't
doesn't it's too much yeah and they
can't run jokes on you all the time yeah
that's true I run trains and joke's on
you they run trains jokes and talk
sports with you non-stop it's a lot
would you ever date twins cat oh and
there they are definitely back in camp
maybe most of their personalities add up
to one
I can't do two like whole personalities
maybe like two halves so it's still like
one we not be dope cat like say like
maybe the guy has like some mental
issues but he's a great time when he's
not depressed the other one you know has
the same secret on and off like how you
feeling this morning on
down I'll jump over to Jerry uh how you
feelin good then next Tuesday
hop down jump over to Bob yeah that
might be the move I like to think about
do mm-hmm you know I'm saying oh
definitely man that's a police siren
what's up good catch well we're trying
to afford a nicer area for the studio
look man do you see sorry I got the in
the black long you do oh you don't feel
great dude oh they don't know what a
hell I know exactly how you need to get
that green long baby
of the green long and you get that
planners fast iotus bro
oh damn to have you on the plants do I
take a bunch of pills with a shove
cabbage down my throat you're so
old-fashioned I know you do athletic
greens man for Adler in my body right
now if honestly dude if you want to
sunflowers flat on my face fully grown
that's because they had you're glowing
dude I feel like I'm glowing it's cuz of
athletic greens it's the ultimate daily
all-in-one health drink with 75 vitamins
minerals and with whole food sourced
ingredients you see you smell like
steamed broccoli the ha ha yeah because
I'm trying to pick up a vegan look man
enough of all the multiple pills all the
complex routines people shooting you
know squash enzymes into the foot it's
crazy
everybody sense it doesn't let it greens
does it all it has prebiotics probiotics
digestive enzymes adaptogens by Robards
yes even Krypton dude it it'll give you
your one-stop shop for everything you
need to feel like your vitamin ated out
of the gate and it's a powder for my
just putting some water and yep right
down the drains right in the morning I
get up I put mine in a glass I put a
scoop I throw one ice cube in there mix
it up dude and then I take it down man I
get my antidepressants with it oh really
half a chantix bro and I'm ready to go
taking step towards a healthier
lifestyle or you're an athlete whatever
you do mhm won't be better athletic
greens takes the guesswork out of
everyday good health why not just try it
jump on over athletic greens calm
/ k 80s and claim me offered today 20
free travel packs valued at 79 bucks
with your first purchase
that's athletic greens calm / K 80s they
are great oh look I love hello fresh
dude I'll just use it the other night
really I got to tell you man hello fresh
dude yeah that's all it's a lot of get a
lot of gay men use it as their stripper
name
hello Fred oh yeah you seen a little
tweak hello Fred oh he out there oh that
boy nice on that pole oh he out there
that's why hey do you want hello fresh
to the crib when I'm up good yeah I'm
good you know dude talk about meals man
it's boxed meals different type of me oh
yeah different type of meat I just did
the one the other day I did the pork
tacos and they were really good but
still it's a different type of meat man
it is hello freshest recipes are
delicious it's the break out of that
dinner rut that you've been waiting for
they have 22 seasonal curated recipes
each weeks you can go online you could
pick your recipes you want to come they
come to the house in the box
unbelievable yeah they got the meat they
got all the items and the recipe dude
and whatever diet you're on low-calorie
vegetarian family-friendly I just want
to stay thick we got you covered
mm-hmm hello fresh cuts out all the
stress of meal planning preparation
don't worry about it all of it takes
less than 30 minutes some even 20
minutes to get that hot food right to
your stupid pie hole get that hot mouth
hitter baby and that's what I'm telling
you right now is that you can handle it
man and it's a great thing if you want
to do something with a youngin if you
got a neighbor a young and a senior
citizen you got a friend that's about to
die or something you guys want to do a
make-a-wish meal or something yeah hello
fresh is that opportunity said hey come
here
here's the directions let's do this
together let's make something together
make something special and listen if you
got that fat friend stays thinking like
you want some yummy sides maybe a
dessert how about you watch some garlic
bread to wash down that thing of
spaghetti yeah how about you want some
cookie dough down yeah let me know when
you do that too
let me beat you in the neck with a sack
of freaking warm poblanos you wanted me
bro you can change your order as much as
you want online you can figure it out
skip a week if you need to hello fresh
is what is going on the best value it's
delicious all right and right now I'm
telling you
that if you go to hellofresh dot-coms
slash ten cats that's 1 0 k 80s and use
the code 1 0 k 80s for 10 free meal oh
wow man including free shipping dang
that's a great deal
Wow go to hello fresh com / 10 cats
hey up and use code 10 cats for 10 free
meals including free shipping you're
gonna love hello fresh what are you
saying that I'll just gonna say that
siren means it's time for a cat's battle
rap ain't nobody beatin little brown son
we keep going through it wait we got
more rap coming in we do what out there
was we're not sorry Nick there's one of
the things we're talking about outside
oh yeah Kwai timbales the kid member all
the loop with that Brad will himself and
the Wolverine also helped out yeah what
about they were saying he's so he really
is 9
apparently he's 9 a lot of people have
conspiracy theories saying that he's
actually 18 oh god I read a DM somewhere
saying that he is actually the bully in
his school and I he's the [ __ ] kid
hmm
give him I don't know give him a break
dude right yeah of course he's not
waking up [ __ ] happy all the time
you know he's a beautiful kid he look
like my sister actually look one of my
sisters he does he's a cute little boy
man
yeah and he's nine years old they said
yeah there's a lot of conspiracy
theories he definitely dress real
swagged out yeah he doesn't dress like a
9 year old does he
mm-hmm I think he was an influencer or
he was 9 years old but he was also like
already somewhat of an influencer like I
don't know if he was getting bullied he
seems like he's living pretty well I
mean well well just just because he
influenced any [ __ ] selling fashion
OVA on the side you know kids are gonna
be mean to someone who looks like that
math unfortunate but that's just what it
is also if I had that condition I'd be
an [ __ ] too dude Wow
- everybody wake up pissed and I'd have
a stick I see everybody in the knees
you can feel my pain just for a second
oh yeah you talk to so don't have that
you don't have so I'm pretty happy I
could see you being a little guy man I
feel like you were a little guy in some
houses but you still have the but the
face the hands you smell weird
[Laughter]
you have tater tots in your pocket Oh
wicked yeah I wish we could get it get
to interview him and to see what do you
know what he's like but he's also 9
years old yeah there's not you know real
deep ever first of all most 9 year olds
are complete [ __ ] they don't care
been around and I mean they're good you
know they'll come in and eat yeah unless
you got a [ __ ] intend or some they're
out - OH for one thing you only candy
and games yeah they're basically just
thought bro it's like a lot of these
dots on his Instagram post same way man
let's-- got candy and dick they minted a
out yeah this boy he looks like uh yeah
they had people there was a lot of
conspiracy theories he was 18
people like um put him into like
different scenarios people even made
videos of him being like older and stuff
it was pretty crazy
and so it's a real conspiracy theory
that he's not 9 he's actually 29 it's a
real conspiracy theory but there's no
evidence behind it yeah I'm sure they
could solve all that just doing a video
inside his class I think they should do
a video him with all his friends all his
friends all at once go [ __ ] you then
fourth grade I talked to someone who it
was like first hand knows Quaid and
can't say who but he said he's a hundred
percent nine years old
they don't know about the rest of it
what kind of life he's living but he's a
hundred percent nine years old poor dude
and just a run put out post too late cuz
he's all anti-bullying and stuff he
confirmed it - he's nine
no I don't give Justin the idea so ship
him to Africa now Willie yeah he loves
Africa he's always in Africa Africa
having big him wells and [ __ ] you think
you want that life man but just to have
you work in brah
dude yeah shout out to Justin Ren and
the funds and stuff he does is he yeah
he's the best he's a great great dude
I'm gonna check him out man yeah yeah I
can't imagine having like a being like
such a little guy I don't I mean it
would be probably really interesting
though but yeah when you're that age man
that would be the toughest haze cuz kids
are just picking on you so much they'd
bully even normal-looking kids hello
miss yeah man we had a kid that was like
good at like doing uh electronics or
something or no he did karate and we and
we ripped into him though and he knew he
could kick your face off
yeah you know he has that [ __ ] Ox
kick with that fat ass the backwards
kick he would do kicks all the time dude
he would like he'd get in rage and then
he would threaten to kick everyone and
he would do a couple of kick or too much
you know just got like freaked out by
the energy of it you know my school was
different man we had a kid with a touch
of the downs and he was a band know so
you touch of the downs you know that
system of downs oh you know there's also
touched the downs and you know Chappell
used to listen to it dude or no swing
Derek is a lot of people are come back
here transplants here's way better ikan
Barry Larkin had more of like a matte
finish everybody probably got picked on
for something would you go would you
guys get picked on if you're if it were
if there was anything I don't feel like
I ever got picked on in school I got
picked on at home mostly and then I
would pick on people at school you take
it out the frustration out oh absolutely
every one my family were [ __ ] really
yeah that's how you show that you love
them though kids just don't really get
it
yeah right oh and you're in just in your
families how it is yeah
what about what were you bullied at all
Chappell uh yeah I mean for being the
black dude that listens the park and
skates and [ __ ] like that yeah that's
fair yeah
[Laughter]
cheerleading out of all the things you
think that's what you get roasted it's
cuz they don't understand it they see
doing all these [ __ ] back well listen
uh [ __ ] lose their life yeah one
Green Day song it ruined it all
oh yeah man like I said there's a kid
with touchdowns on my school and I
always picked them first when we pick
teams weights because you stronger than
everybody you just had that fire in him
you just hand him off the ball bye good
luck tackling Rodney yeah nobody can
tackle him we called him big red
actually yeah yeah I also had red hair
and literally the fattest ass you've
ever seen he was like Maurice jones-drew
we couldn't tackle him dude I picked
them first every time yeah he's big red
they should have I'm trying to think if
we uh if we had I mean we definitely had
some Wildcats growing up dude we had a
gun I'm older guy bucket yeah we had a
guy who was at our school for so long
that they just made him a janitor at
woman yeah but he still carried a book
this new mr. Lehri yeah and I was in
class yeah huh yep he carried a bunch of
[ __ ] but everybody called him mr. Larry
at a certain point and he his big thing
was when you were at the urinal because
you he you know he was in fifth grade
he's probably 17 so he come in behind
your piss over you into the urine and
then watch you pee oh no you'd watch you
be we just kind of be behind you me be
like Oh what is that you know yeah
there's Larry yeah mr. Larry mr. Larry
it's ridiculous but um dude I've seen
this kid named buck yet all the time
it's all he ever said was bucket bucket
yeah but was he like a dope basketball
player no no no he had full body hair
early oh and it's always tough like
bucket not he just say bucket
[ __ ] it [ __ ] it just not stop talk to
himself bucket yeah
was he also a janitor no which would
have been I know what it imperfect dude
why I had a buddy who was in fifth grade
his name was brand and mine was Brendan
right they cause BB and BB zwi real we
always Hawk non-stop right I chew my
dunkaroos my capri-sun my orange slices
Lunchables you my tote meal Pyatt so
much meaning him we're friends I love
oatmeal pies but I would share half of
it with him and then he I married make
fun of him cuz he'd always pee and he
pulls pants you know that when you were
little you pull your pants all the way
down oh yeah he still did in fifth grade
so I used to grab my pee and shake him
right shake it oh yeah he would just go
everywhere I thought it was so funny but
then apparently it was a real problem
and over the intercom system they're
like hey who's ever peeing on the walls
we're gonna catch it and we're gonna
catch you and you'd be dealt with
accordingly
dude I think BB huh uh I think you guys
designed this where I get my inspiration
from I think yeah that's on your side my
side being BB pieced this thing up dude
but I got caught because he's doing it
again and I and I was account whatever
some big deal and I shook him in the
future came in to grab me by the hand
the whole school oh there's the PPK
everybody be king no praise bad press
all the kids love me man nobody was
saying and there's four kids though good
[Laughter]
spark these memories in a while dude we
had our school they had a heater a
furnace in the bathroom and say kids are
going there and urinated on it all and
that was like the big thing to do if you
had a bunch of piss and
to go in there and just unleash it on
that hot furnace and it would just steam
up the whole bath asada but you couldn't
see yes you'd have a bunch of kids just
wandering around just in like in piss
miss sauna oh dude yeah and so they then
they had of all the boys come into the
gym and we had a female principal miss
McManus and she said and some kid is
submitted to it he wasn't even doing it
some kid is just a total wimp yeah if
you were like damn you did it actually
gave him a little bit of cloud I think
hell yeah that's why he did it yeah but
it was still fun people did that forever
man just running through the piss with
my woes bro with my woes but yeah yeah I
think the kid looks like a damn child I
leave that kid alone man yeah well we do
have more submission for cats better
cats rap battle and they're pretty fired
like you said little brow still the
champion because of that he might win
forever
you think we should retire him no no no
you gotta bring the heat man this is a
mile this is a mile yeah this ain't this
is a mile that's chatter do I really
like cheddar Bob and Oscar Gaucho at a
baby chatter Bob sound self in the leg a
little bit man chatter Bob in the house
Doug it's all good no we didn't have a
similar nose kind of do you guys look I
don't know there he is put a mullet on
that picture
that's Theo duh oh my gosh chatter Bob
what is that man's name
Evan Jones look at that other picture up
up above right above that one yes you
don't fell on hard hard time
Jesus dude that's like cane rounds like
cocaine Brown dang yeah shutout shatter
Bob that I can't believe that yeah yeah
yeah we're eight mile or breakfast club
your cheddar Bob let's hear these raps
dog I don't think we should retire he's
the king man you got it you have to
bring such fire to beat [ __ ] brows
fair enough it'll be the reigning champ
you think forever no there's a fire
tonight I don't say fire got on that
King Ramses don't say fire make you feel
awkward this comes from Stephen Lacoste
aka Don the [ __ ] is fun don don king of
sting fam what's good a longtime
listener love what you boys do for real
y'all make my day I bet even episode
drops so thanks Don salute okay I
appreciate y'all vo my dog I 190
Covington right around the corner
Madisonville same- would gang brush of
Brendan see ass in the woollens March
14th
oh yeah doggies get to it I see
everybody's sending in their rap [ __ ] so
I figured I'd do the same you let me
know what y'all think let's go off 190
son I'm kind of feeling sued already is
the beat hot nick is an original beat
denim listening Gang Gang buzz buzz
chatterbox your culture it's Theo von
and Brennan's job
King and
he's confident brah like like the hoodie
Thursday in the buzz buzz - like bie
don't be touching me pedigree
I'll just be my head busters CTE zero a
twisting tree laughing in the MST [ __ ]
[ __ ] G chin got the recipe great
I said recipe Brendon thinking stuff to
me until the day casters chill with the
dick amusement it's all for my art -
you're riding around cruising and see
your faces on a poster for movement
she was so fired and dance on my foot
like this
King Wow yeah that [ __ ] was pure fire I
don't know little brown sesame hair cut
my talk you two now yeah I see [ __ ]
curl dawg you got that baby cape dude
that [ __ ] [ __ ] well you're gonna grow
some seared come on now get them curls
dude dude in children when I was in
Canada yeah do not wear hockey huh me
really oh I have a hockey stick these
[ __ ] god damn that was the crazy
thing about Don's I would have to go
back and listen again to even get all of
it me too
I actually had him send the lyrics to us
too so we can look through those later
but yeah but this is a familiar face who
also came with me down going gene the
sting records here we go
well that's probably with the tent
let's go hard on us talk about a snap in
soccer
rats and at least pigtail
oh sure just waking up
exactly that lazy Bronson Action Bronson
discover Brendon when he put him on a
back in the middle of the cage noise
counter steps hopped up on that stage
and he started spare facts then he got a
couple lives and he knew it was a wrap
back to the game he never gonna attack
we put Shawn in the stats came up in the
mouthpiece now he's killing on the beach
and spend a weekend on the road and cut
the feel we can cross the speaking
Creole caught up on that body now he's
preaching other people started in
reality and turned into a fantasy never
could have dreamed how intense the
demand will be and in the front party in
the back
the gang has sold out shows got that
monkey off his back
the wave of positivity who spreads
across the mat there's little words away
from that he drops and benders lap he
love you dog love you for that kitty cat
looking like a host hole smash anything
with that age
sniff looking like new arenas haunted
like that counselor at the rehab
[Music]
but still repairing it [ __ ] brother
[Music]
with big Pacific disease
field are nothing like the before
picture like a Cornish domestic ass
loose a was a great got a tickle my life
[Music]
their necessity [ __ ] Rolly buddy we
were laughing over it but after he said
Nick looks like dead Luke Perry he goes
no seriously Nick you look like that
look boy these were BC and actually
little brows came in he gave a do we
want to hear it now he gave a full mix
version of his song hunter per se here
we go man [ __ ] is thick out here using
stay where music is audio to the culture
Brennan and Theo fighter and wait I
gotta go in and go hard in the paint I
do not think I am and Flo black rifle
coffee I'm ready to go
I need a sponsor I am a monster about to
open up with this at my concerts Poe is
contained just browser outrageous
thicker than girls leather Instagram
famous damn probably like I'm fresh off
Quito see you read like Andrew since you
know every summer is like the great
Bambino gonna take the case oh and the
case Cerritos through my DMS
a couple of you try to couldn't beat him
quick plan like Nintendo DS you don't
want the smoke like Joey Diaz meaning
y'all edible just got my eye brother I
didn't nothing an incredible britain son
hit me up he said it's too loud in the
club can you pick me up
[Music]
this will like you want speech these
already have enough change
strong
and the sting King in the stink
in the stink I stink
[Music]
she's on the stream it's Brendan and the
old fighter in Creole shoutout New
Orleans and shout-out to Co Colorado
more specifically powder Brendan came in
with a chip on his shoulder but is still
gold and yet is still fire if you don't
like King Aniston you're a liar Brenda's
got like a thousand different hustle one
of them's that Nordstrom Rack two wins
hi here's my fee we hear you loud and
clear your son on the email like please
get me out of here as went through howdy
here watching the Irishman eating pizzas
drinking half a beer now under Theo von
looking like the type of dude the trans
Arita songs tweet senator Wes with a
snapback on but to hit the crib in turn
snapchat is that we still mess with you
18:11 Pico Boulevard go get ahead Derek
and cat y'all doing great Thursday
upload not a minute late y'all wanted to
rap ahead a demonstrate brand new studio
y'all feelin great putting Chris Delano
in this place now let's go and get
Chinna
[Music]
and sting Riesling
[Music]
yeah you can't [ __ ] sir can't [ __ ] with
little brows bro those other boys are
nice but that dude brings the bangers I
feel like he needs to drop the 97 hot
well we need YouTube to pick a winner
between Don Lacoste's the first guy from
Covington and Papa Bear and then we'll
put out to a vote between Austin our
first guy probably four dude I gotta say
this about dawn straight up dawn thank
uh I'll have to listen to Don again
[Laughter]
[Applause]
chatter bombs away I'm over here - don't
Quaid and bales media they were so good
they remixed my voice box bro so weird
this dope though man also Austin though
browser Champlin we put him up a vote
against vicious and dominated da Matta
85% he took vision and vicious was the
guy with the UH with the kit with the
shirt on right the bass too vicious was
the guy who had like the screen record
and he had like the waveform oh yeah man
Brow's just says talent was all three of
the guys got talent man the one guy I
love the fact that Don uh came in which
one was dumb big boy Dom was the first
guy okay nice I love that Don came in
straight out of Louisiana I'll load that
Papa Bear came in and he had made fun of
his tattoo you had man - homeboy I
thought it was great I thought it was
good work - it's just I just had some
questions all right carry on oh yes some
questions that ended in exclamation
point there was no respect dude and he
submitted it to get ripped up but anyway
he came but he like came back at us I
know that [ __ ] was [ __ ] pretty good
ya mom's spaghetti no it's all great
it's gonna be tough to beat [ __ ]
little brown especially with the remix
the street mixtape he made for us
I look man I'm on offense aside by I
think it's the I love I love Papa Bear I
love everything he did I was fantastic I
think it's the Don and little brown
obviously let the fans decide also I
guess make sure you send me the the
remix so you can walk up to I think we
let the fans decide who is um know who
know computer games from the growl okay
two votes or just at least one vote
right now I got to hear it again man I
can't make a choice immediately you're
on you're not right now I need to hear
it later on I need hear when I'm by
myself or someone I've had like a
relaxing afternoon yeah we got time we
only do this every couple of weeks so
little brows goes hard in the paint do
the president about to get also there be
and their styles are so different to the
firt the Don had a beat that romana me a
little bit oh can you can you just put a
sample of it up again they each reminded
me of a different kind of King family
yeah yeah look in the bus lamp Oh beacon
man damn [ __ ] just gang gang buzz
buzz till I di e don't be touching me
but keep touching me culture culture
today some vultures peak the pedigree a
savage team ahead Buster's CTE Derek
twisting tree laughing in the MSE [ __ ]
[ __ ] G chin got the recipe
I said recipe Brendan thinking stuff to
me that you'll probably thinking mixing
deco with us to your team
[Music]
boosting and see your faces donut poster
food that's just a man it's a little
browsing him man
I think we throw up between brows and
Don were know between dawn and Oh help
me out knit a bear Papa Bear and let
them decide and then one of them goes up
against brows object it's just too much
for me I'm gonna do it it's waste your
time I'm exhausted
you two that this [ __ ] was that a lot of
time I was dancing a lot of time what
else we got a lot of work shout out to
those although that's a lot of work what
do y'all think culture corner let's get
into it what do you guys think yeah over
wool but over home holler bear little
bear Papa what about the caterpillar
caterpillar is that's hard right can't
the need Davis they call it Don said it
was a G and Papa Bear said I look like
dead Luke Perry and I still like Papa
Bear more why it's a good point
mmm it just shows how lovable he is and
here's a lady is she gonna rap too no
we're not a female rap man I love female
rappers dude it's sex really
ah a girl can drop some [ __ ] bars like
who like Billie Eilish she goes she of
age yes she is of age yes love I don't
like Nicki Minaj that's what I'm gonna
like cardi B cardi B's okay oh my god
how about stallion mega stallion Italian
Jew she is a stallion I don't listen her
music she's so [ __ ] fun I haven't
heard her yo you you don't need to just
see her I'm trying to think who else
I've listened to that's a female rappers
disease must be one name ma but I feel
like she stole bobby schmurder this
whole thing do you remember that oh well
Bobby's always felt like that but risen
and as soon as he went to jail the only
American yeah who else are female
rappers Oh technine
well mama Mia
do we got a free takashi dog i do was
about to get killed somewhere he's still
gonna kill his colorful ass is hilarious
funny - clowning everybody out then we
got to bring him oh dude Iggy Azalea can
get it I love burn so bad at rapping
though dude how dare you well how dare
you the brat Brina oh I know one Iggy
song by heart which one suspended for a
week
[Laughter]
let me talk to Human Resources yeah
you're all about a week do you want to
hear it I'm here yeah you know my heart
spin it [ __ ] [ __ ]
eggie eggie eggie [ __ ] oh [ __ ] to make
you into a geeky [ __ ] illy wetter than
an amazon taste is cutie silly fairly
type and clearly a modem ah so good
look at my crack aftershock TC Cheney
goes
[Laughter]
like he didn't all night rapping in news
Alabama represents our live TV and
freezes on the length personally for us
now write and tell us what we're about
to hear there's a freestyle okay I'm
just gonna pick it up a restyle let me
sit back go ahead Marshall okay
years ago they tried it
years ago they tried it put me in it did
you want to try to read something from
your book
yeah you can't blame him they try to do
a music here's the good they tried done
your free trial is over ten dollars to
do a spoken word for us now write write
and tell us what we're about to hear
you're just a freestyle okay I'm just
gonna pick it up writes down let me sit
back go ahead Marshall okay
years ago they tried it years ago with
each other do you want to try to read
something from your book yeah that's not
saying that's choke and Nick didn't
choke that guy had a tough time there's
one part we can hear we couldn't hear
but he goes this this is live dude
you're mangia first up let's go to the
culture corner what do you got video
Nick you can't blame him for not you
can't blame him not after what they try
to do two years ago and what is that if
that happens in your culture cat what
are you gonna do you got what happened
you got to move to the next village over
can't be rabbit early in the movie just
not you gotta move to next village
sweating so bad
are you do your sweat sweat smells like
sook
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
yeah let's sink this girl let's think
are good because maybe we'll send in a
rap video clear hi I'm Brendan my name
is Claire I'm from Wisconsin I have some
tattoos to show you're forcing my ink
these are not them so here's some of my
arm I have two lines and then a thin
line on my wrists here it's supposed to
be like a fancy glove that I'm always
wearing and the one here was just I was
just drunk and it's just two lines that
my ex-boyfriend did who cheated on me so
yep those are there forever and I'll
show you an igloo that I have a bunch of
other girls have it too or my Eskimo
sisters we all have that same egg Luther
so yeah thank you guys I love you guys
Gang Gang buzzbuzz buzzbuzz girl Xie
freak
mmm you freak there's nothing wrong with
that so her and her friends all hooked
up with the same gentleman and a saint a
to have a few Eskimo brothers out there
in the world and it's a tight fraternity
is it yeah you talk about Dana White
I said a few said a few now he might be
the top of it I got a selfie Mick
obviously favored in this girl cuz she's
out of Wisconsin and I respect that but
also uh yeah it seemed like she might
have an alcohol problem I think she
might have some sort of addiction issues
the other thing is is I don't know if
she realized it so today cuz I don't
know if she realized it though that her
her boyfriend was actually drawing the
predator sign on her
that's from predator when the predator
would zoom in I need to kill you or when
he would remember when he was start
laughing at the end we saw 1 to 10 know
the predator alien starts laughing like
that we need about to blow himself up
and then Arnold's running come on do it
Jimmy and then predators like this deep
no no one was the whole movie no
predator I'm not watching it now that's
that that's her tattoo doing the numbers
are counting down that's what it is so
yeah you have the mark of the beast
basically yeah also shows up in a
biblical law I think you would look up
mark up the beat mark of the beast I
think yeah apparently you know he
cheated on her but also I like her
attitude she's an eskimo fellow Eskimo
sister and she's you know she's down
she's let her man draw on her with a
[ __ ] tattoo gun yeah that's pretty
cool that's true you got a woman that's
really down for you if they do that she
seems great seems like a like a good
time woody tattoos mean in some of the
different communities around the world
guys I think well for Asians I feel like
it depends some I think look like you're
a part of the triad but you're not and
then there are others that just means
I don't even know - I can totally check
bounced ago guy yeah I wanted all my
nerd punk rock tattoos you have to have
a ball on my chest just flag raw power
Iggy Pop I'm so did you say you have a
black power tattoo Black Flag I'm Henry
Rollins man but then he did say power no
raw power okay
yeah raw power what is that from a like
plant-based diet or what is it legit
question oh yeah just like g-star genes
no it's you probably the Stooges it's
one of their albums oh right on
yes cool oh here's another guy who also
went to prison then it sound like you
wants a prison in New Hampshire dude
that's what it sounds like your based on
your tattoo you went to a friendly
prison yeah you went to prison you know
finally present Pleasantville prison
this is Nathan from Ireland oh hey
Brendan hey field what's up I thought
the sender sent some tattoos so I just
got that chance I never forsakes a nice
lady with parts this that's sixteen and
just say you got more of the devil [ __ ]
so you got the Grim Reaper header
what's the best one has to be this dang
game buzzbuzz buzzbuzz youngest fun I
love that Oh monster tattoo that got
some tits on her huh the way that she
doubled tell me it's that was the best
work the the the pirate got a little
dicey the pirate the pirate he gets a
little dicey went in the color it seemed
like a variety of artists as well that
this gentleman had really you know kind
of accentuate his body yeah look at the
tits on the Red Devil there that's good
I was that at it yeah that's a kneecap
isn't it that's his elbow that's her tip
yeah that's why you put it there so it
looks bigger when he goes like this I
like that that's smart
yeah smart we couldn't get one yeah but
the devil we don't know what the other
side looks like yeah I could see the
devil showing up at one tit I'd be like
oh I knew it
his chest looks a little like it wasn't
that we got a sink this dude's ink man
first of all with this much ink bro you
probably you also have should have a Hep
C tested over there also a lot of these
tattoos I feel like you drank downs of
Guinness and then decide to get that
thing on your chest that thing it's just
also a very prisoners tattoo yeah it's
I'm a friendly prison tattoo yeah yeah
man you got a lot of stuff going on to
you so make up your mind the devil you
got the beach you got the lighthouse you
got your whole Johnny Depp yeah you got
Johnny Depp hire it yeah I think you got
a lot of uh I think that parrot looks
like [ __ ] can we go back to the parent
Fernandez we're supposed to sink you
think and here's the other thing that's
me first of all it looks like me if you
look at that one that definitely looks
like you I don't know I don't know the
best thing when that foam finger at the
winner at the game oh okay spray a sock
game has the tooth below oh yeah that's
cool
scroll up to that ship here and that
pair does look like older that looks
like it's older than some of the other
pants with that chick is hot with that
bird though with the what we call that a
brassiere
yeah man with in front tits or that's
just a really shitty Johnny Depp tattoo
can't tell um oh that shit's fire
that shit's dope yeah a little sexy
devil that's good work this is the same
guy yeah oh damn he well he went on the
head wow did that Mardi Gras mask in the
back I love that happy Mardi Gras today
is Mardi Gras is it Mardi Gras Tuesday
oh [ __ ] Fat Tuesday dude can't believe
you didn't know this out can't believe
you don't get a reminder with any
holiday that has fat in it
yeah sorry no it's fine man
I'm just joking cost you some beads so
you can get your tits out my tits are on
my butt get him out
I got 11 D's on my butt these are the
biggest tits
I shake my nipples move to my butt
uh this guy dead look man I don't even
know where to start maybe you got
flowers on the head you got a butterfly
on the back Ian neck you got the Forrest
Gump haircut there's a lot going on
you'd like a damn museum dude you look
like a UH like a little bit of a museum
you know all I know is that parrot some
[ __ ] yeah so it's good work yeah I
like the I like a lot of admit I'm like
you gotta be careful at the Lighthouse
though man we told you papa bear came
and had that dick on his arm bro his
father died at a lighthouse when he was
16 his did ya know he say he's a big fan
of shutter island' he did it oh my bad
man I thought I heard him say man
no well hope your dad so but if he isn't
then I miss him too oh he does he does
is it blown up I'm gonna say right now
it is jro D de que ATS LA and we'll
share it on the cat's Instagram I still
think he's a criminal or abouts always
on the run he's got a panty on his head
he is submitted via the hashtag debate
club which everybody should do
[Music]
Oh
[Music]
or John wait
you say that's my dad he's a superhero
don't you pay attention in the movie -
that was crazy it was it was really good
it was really it was better than some of
the tattoos we've seen today by far
here's the thing man you gotta respect
that I love that wait what is dad
dressed up Tommy look at the leather
[ __ ] vest he's dressed as my mom must
have moustache but some moms do like
some moms dude though you know sometimes
they catch my mom and the right light
like all right you know most - dude op
top down along with a girl one time she
had whiskers all over said you gotta go
get your whiskers down I can go t [ __ ]
you have a mirror that doesn't see hair
you got a whisker down a little
yeah you think she's just dying piecing
getting your convertible in the Sun hits
just right they say you know she looks
like Hulk Hogan yea orsa with you might
just be it's Terry
what was this woman asking about dude
John wig [ __ ] relax really didn't this
whole [ __ ] revenge tour start
somebody killed his dog it has some real
darkness man yeah I know in some areas
dog have a lot more there's a lot more
of a bounty on their head you know I
grew up in the area a lot of dogs died
yeah you know we would go pull dogs off
the highway and bury him all the time
when I was growing up doing the Lord's
work man
yeah burying them do you think all dogs
go to heaven mm-hmm no no some of these
[ __ ] stay down here
and some even go lower you had some of
those little ones those chihuahuas all
Chihuahuas go to hell we someone dressed
up the other day look somebody who
dressed it up it looks like kind of just
like Nicki Minaj yeah some of those
little ones man if I here's my thing if
a frisbee will kill it it's not a doll
easy litmus test yeah throw a frisbee
hits it in the mouth it dog doesn't lift
not a dog not a dog so standard for dog
city I think it's fair I think it's
legit fair yeah but I think that this
man's dad is having a tough time and
I've never seen John wick I've never
actually seen him either so I think my
brother told me the plot I'm like hold
on I love Keanu but dog dies and he goes
on a revenge tour I'm out yeah yeah
Marley and me I think was it's kind of
sounds like a ripoff of Marley in a
minute me myself and Marley or is here
some fourth the new is that what is that
wick seven with Hurston Ford with the
dog westbound I think speaking of wicks
man shoutout to that candle company
what's the candle company that says his
candles all the time I don't know he's
got a boulder though joint Piedmont a
yeah oh that's right over candle company
so you want to give him a shot out they
always send nice stuff there's some
beautiful candle beautiful candles
here's the other thing about just alone
do when he's doing Rambo he's not so
much steroid yeah he's on so much roids
and there you go he's the flights to
Vietnam hurts all these innocent people
and he just has a knife and then comes
back in part two and that makes a part
three he's 75 years old and makes a part
three it goes back to Vietnam even
though there's no war going on just
start slaughtering people well let's ask
cat let's get you guys out of Detroit
what is y'all side of the story when it
comes to Rambo or just Vietnam in
general well let's start with Rambo but
yeah yeah you're right yeah you know I'm
yeah good call cuz we have our opinion
yeah yeah y'all did it yeah yeah I think
my family is a little different of a
situation my grandpa actually fought
with the Americans and then once the
Americans pulled out he was taken to
prison as a prisoner of war for fighting
with Americans
no I didn't know this story was gonna go
that way so we're very Israel may be
about him yet no not yet but we like to
be that's so crazy there's not a movie
about this doesn't that dunk Kurt no
Dunkirk is a bunch of we told about like
British people that couldn't catch a
ferry I think you're right it's never
told from like the other perspective no
white dude coming and what did they do
to your grandpa your dad my grandpa
what'd they do to your grandpa uh he was
in jail for a couple years and then
eventually they just let him go you good
dog what's we want what do you think if
he would have been a white guy they
would have let him go or no do you think
it had anything to do that he was of
Vietnamese sir no I don't think they
would let him go if he was white just
out of principle yeah but people are
like yeah I don't know I wish had this
new more copy you know is everything my
life story overall welcome
so ramble when you guys as culture it's
not a hero it's just kind of like a guy
that's bothering everything he's more of
a villain correct yeah I guess a villain
or like just a weird white guy who just
keeps coming back even though we're not
fighting anymore yeah yes it's almost
like a um like one of those door-to-door
sales like those people selling those
magazines you know but his magazines
that bullets henna or a Jehovah's
Witness yeah can you get rid of him MJ
doves boy he just keeps pushing it on
like Scientology dude I to jovis witness
come in one time when I was living in
Tucson and played video games with me
for like three hours bro did you buy the
books huh do you buy the books I didn't
buy anything he gave me this picture of
a tiger and then uh and that was it
thank God a really good chill are you
still friends this day no hmm
what else you got Nick that's it doesn't
I feel like we get caught on one thing
and we we wasted a half an hour laughing
other guy trying to rap I do I cry till
my insides are done we'll put a link to
the video in the top of the YouTube Jim
what do you have to say man any
eventhough so quiet very quiet
okay what's good ever since you got a
girlfriend you've been so quiet ever
since we made fun of his ass
[Laughter]
in spite of that jacket at least
somebody put fart in this jacket at the
store huh it looks like a stinky jacket
oh wait I did spill some what did we
miss Jim what ever since you ever since
you the thing happened you got a
girlfriend you being broke quiet
presenter I don't think so yeah it is
ever since gender happened ever since
gender happened he got drunk and
admitted that you liked him
and fluffy white chest uppers and fluffy
white chest tonsils
ever since you realize you really [ __ ]
up but he [ __ ] much a drink on the
side of the street for down seven
bottles of [ __ ] sake to see you the
longer you stay the more I get enjoyable
and the jiggles you felt like you
dropped the ball on that maybe a little
chin maybe on purpose maybe but I got to
enjoy as long as half hours it wasn't as
a long time we heard from her since is
she okay
I'm sure she's fine get it together dude
she did she would she's had her she okay
she was way better once she wasn't
associated with us anymore yeah she's
doing better now spreading a better man
yeah sure I got a bunch of creeps trying
to throw a hit man Knicks almost
forgetting that he just saw that he did
Iggy's [ __ ] what are you crazy I knew
worse - I wish I knew more he was ready
for the win his whole life for them he
went in I respect it man shut up - Nick
did um yep I'm gonna be in Maui Hawaii
on March 7th and I'm gonna be at the
Ryman
Nashville on April 17th we're now he
would place a place called the castle
theater hmm it's it's at the Mac it made
me say I hope it is it would be great in
there yeah he's so sick wouldn't it yeah
I wish I did construction I'm a Tacoma
this weekend Thursday Friday Saturday
we're in a gingerbread house we sold
real gingerbread houses to people come
on yeah check out the second bedroom
have a bite
[Laughter]
bring your nice and yeah oh you get
locked in the closet shoot your way
don't say nothing make another door yeah
no there's no gingerbread house and to
come I don't think but I'm there
Thursday Friday Saturday and then New
Orleans Detroit Toronto Minneapolis
Atlanta all in March one night only
theater run and we're about to announce
Austin Texas March 19th
dude you gotta meet up with Don down
there in New Orleans but you want to see
you
March 14th maybe I should have done
[ __ ] bring me on stage and rap I
would be City sick Don GM me dawg oh
we're also displaced songs many I'd be
so nervous probably maybe it won't be
maybe he's a professional
no no he's wrapped just [ __ ] make him
wrap him in my dick open up went hard in
the paint you went so hard Chappelle you
updates brother we don't ask you all
right yeah yeah well you might be on the
road with me tell ya come with me no fun
man yeah party party good to see you
guys man yeah thank you guys thank coach
corner Nick oh yeah so hard turnin Gang
Gang bro